I brought a prod a thing here notice  there's a device right here I didn't  know I love it when guests bring things  yeah you know it seems kind of like a  thing show so it was like let's see so  this is a this is my trusty looper pedal  that I always have and and I thought I  would maybe make something and you if  you want to add stuff to the loop  because you can add stuff okay I have  not done this before I don't know how to  do this okay okay okay so here we are  I'm gonna start by moving all the dials  to zero nominal I'm gonna turn these up  to 64% and I'm gonna disengage the MIDI  clock sync system and I'm gonna start  the joy of music so now you can add  anything you want and just when you're  ready to go up I'll hit record a corn  cob corn cob corn cob  [Applause]  it's Danny Welbeck nemeth it's really  good I don't have one because I would  never go anywhere if you had one of  those I would quit you would quit and  you would be right to quit  you